welcome to this video Grandmaster Goff's
teen the opponent from Israel very good
veteran Grandmaster been on let's say 25
50 rating for for ages let's see we got
a hedgehog with my transposed to already
replaced e5 but normally okay is doing
something else entirely interesting way
to play probably he wants to answer D
for with d5 no update this I didn't
expect okay well here I don't want to
play 90 for this kind of maybe it what
would have been interesting and yeah
well not Lots much to do about it now
let's see what happens that's that's a
bit of an unusual kind of Hedgehog
because the night went on a 625
nite nite b5 is 98 it's not really doing
much
yeah I don't really see any particularly
great way to try to try to punish what
he did this is this is just a normal way
to play try to expose the d6 weakness by
94 but he will play Queen on the long
diagonal setting up a pin which is not
very convenient so maybe you prepare
that yeah this looks quite solid for
black cannot expect anything great yeah
that's interesting ok I'll do that it's
a bit uncommon but I have some hopes to
play 9 p-5 or 94 Bishop have 60 rock t
to Queenie for may be all right now
while he's got d6 protected so but I
think I can go here f5 I mean I cannot
believe that five as possible so just
centralized the night do you i hope i
can take and c5 hangs ok i know i will
now I return of course need to block
this and now is this night be five on
the on the cards my day for maybe 9 a-4
even blocking and allowing bishops III
I thought maybe 9 a-6 would have been
interesting I'm aiming for a form trying
to block the five long term it we can
still fall but I don't see how he could
make any use of that okay I'm doubling
on the default now yeah just slowly
improving the position okay this may be
now II 596 this is some this is
important okay oops this was free move
sort of like a pre move I didn't want to
play a five I could have taken it he
didn't though surprisingly enough it
would have been good i guess i can't get
the King out of this ok so I'm somewhat
behind on the clock but the position is
is quite nice actually I one level five
is an idea but I think he's got this
good t5 some small there that's the good
fight but wrong really
okay not sure what this is really
accomplishing yeah okay I can do this
okay now 85 or not yeah what else what
else really okay so should I take here
take here let's look at it to at the end
I can take on c5 though which is okay
let's do that trying to keep control
over the default it's probably far more
important than then any material gain
time morning c5 is also really weak
Kim Knight f6 this route d6
how very tricky position what I don't
like is that my king is somewhat open
here it could could be a problem and of
course I'm down on time at that's the
most problematic part
you six is hanging but yeah yeah like
that check can be trouble
mmm not sure we are taking on g7 is
probably not right maybe this when I
have eight is not really a threat here
check check now he has a perpetual no I
didn't even think of that but okay if he
wants to do a perpetual and so much down
a long time that I probably should
welcome that check check
check-check
I don't really have time to think of
something great ok now I do that you
know because i have king of 3m getting
the g3 porn check and i have relatively
little danger of losing here jack yeah
okay it's a draw no no way to to do
anything yeah which is okay given the
tower situation certainly had a winning
position Lee no no real chance to
convert this around here why the sub D
close to winning but I didn't have any
time that so let's say let's check this
briefly this looks very nice for white
but I didn't didn't really managed a
totally winning position so here it
starts Roxy sixes bet I am damn this is
better because it lets the Queen I did
it gets the Queen to the Queen side and
not near my king which is helpful I
computer points out this move which is a
nice defense intending this a black
always has counter player against my wii
king so it will never be a totally
totally easy thing yeah now here 96 was
good immediately I because i'm covering
here that's very important of course
yeah and yeah this looks very nice for
right now i can i can do something like
that and
the sea porn now I'll computer gives a
win here but that's very tricky to do
and yeah with a little time and their
auntie I think it's very Jewish check
check check simply because of the
pipette shots and it's hard to poop see
I could have one with King age three
okay yeah that's not so difficult era
really he now must play this one I'm
turn that I'm going to win yeah of
course I do yeah check okay I don't know
went for this which I also thought
should be quite yet for wide actually
and here this this looks quite
suspicious from black I think but ok 14
seconds so here here we got it recently
because the pawns will exchange yeah
tough fights with with some shop with
some chances but I spent too much time
in the initial phase of the game alright
thanks for watching